a couple of investors and entrepreneurs
so so we we should use the opportunity
now and have another 1 minute pitch so
remember to use the frame we gave you
earlier there's little sentence
explaining who you are what your name is
the target audience which market you're
addressing which program you're solving
and what your secret sauces
the bus is packed with ideas and with
young people from the world over
traveling through Africa they're not
here to see the spectacular countryside
but to develop software that will make a
difference and make a breakthrough in
the global startup market we are
developing something coming from the
problem that we have been fully the
heart breaks all over Africa spell in
Zimbabwe I'm swabbing myself
so what we're building here is an
application to help health care workers
be able to coordinate and communicate
effectively between all Stevens's
involved during times of political
outbreaks and issues we are application
or our system NGOs and government to
coordinate and to coordinate people
centered responses in terms of crisis
they've already travelled over 1,000
kilometres
Lonnie's team even uses the brakes to
cut and polish their idea Americans
Indians Africans and Europeans are all
working together here they're
brainstorming over business plans and
ideas to show potential investors
through after the passenger pigeon
question booth our products I'm hoping
that we are also going to be able to get
a lot of funding and supports for the
products and initiatives that we are
floating on this
the idea for the Africa bus came from a
German Fabian Carlos school he'd already
organized a few startup tours in Europe
he knows that great expectations are
also riding on the bus the participants
have a range of expectations
we've got people looking for a new
project who really want to get a new
startup going and business people who
are already quite successful and just
want to get to know the African
continent because they might want to do
business here someday they're about to
reach their main stop Johannesburg
now under the gaze of Nelson Mandela
it's time to get down to business
jabber Lonnie's group tries to sell
their idea to venture capitalists they
have three minutes to make an impression
the time is almost up and the investors
are still skeptical their idea for an
app didn't raise any eyebrows now we now
need to put more emphasis on our
business models in communicative ability
above even if the investors held back
their funding at least everybody earned
applause what I've seen today this is
some really really exciting ideas and
some great teams you really understand
what they you know what the objectives
is an in game and us think that they can
execute there's some other guys who I
think still need a little bit of polish
but I think right concept I think is a
lot of talent this first meeting with
potential investors was also an exciting
moment for Fabian Carlos school teams
devoting the venture capitalists just
tore apart some of the teams but they
didn't let that discourage them they
said they would stick with that business
model and improve on it then on day 5
they'll present a successful business
model that will make an impact and
include a concept that will make some
money off get redeemed
but to do all that before the end of the
tour the travelers will have to burn the
late-night oil they have lots of
discussing and programming to do before
they head on to Cape Town only a few
lucky ones allow themselves some time
off for leisure